plus de voir des des extraterrestres sur
terre avant ils sont là ils sont
toujours là ah oui ils sont là
ils sont là et je peux même vous dire
que je viens de découvrir quelque chose
que je vais révéler au grand public
dans quelques semaines je pense comme je
l'ai dit la dernière fois sur ce même
plateau qui voyage dans le temps et j'en
apporte l'épreuve alors il vous reste
longtemps un extra-terrestre si on n'a
pas du tout les mêmes notions de temps
ce que vous disiez la dernière fois
c'est à dire que pour eux un an c'est
quoi c'est un jour pour eux quoi en nous
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas quel est
le différentiel entre leur temps à eux
et notre temps à nous j'ai donné la
dernière fois parce que c'est un peu
difficile de d'imaginer les notions de
temps différents j'ai expliqué une image
que tout le monde a bien compris c'est à
dire que si sur la planète des
extraterrestres vous avez le président
de la République qui dit vous allez
visiter la planète Terre mais vous allez
voyager dans le temps et toi le pilote
de l'ovni numéro 1 tu vas aller en Loren
toi le pilote de la de l'ovni numéro de
2023 qui va en 2023 et bien pendant 2023
ans on va voir des ovnis alors que ils
sont restés peut-être que 15 jours parce
qu'ils vont revenir sur Planète d'accord
et qu'est-ce qui te fait dire
Jean-Claude il y a des nouveaux éléments
sur les oui maman parce que ça tient la
route sur le plan de la physique
qu'est-ce que ça change en fait qui
voyage dans le temps
ça explique énormément de choses ça
explique comment les voyez autant de la
Bible par exemple autant de Dumas barata
des Indiens des Hindous pour et donc ils
ont la possibilité de voyager dans le
temps puisqu'on les voit toujours dans
l'histoire des hommes tels que
l'Écriture nous les a transmises et on
ne les voit pas changer c'est à dire que
leur technologie n'évolue pas oui
Jean-Claude est-ce que ce sont depuis
tout ce temps les mêmes extraterrestres
qui viennent en groupe Terry voyagent
dans le temps mais ce sont les mêmes qui
viennent d'une planète que vous auriez
identifié par exemple non non je n'ai
pas évidemment
identifié de planète et ils viennent
peut-être d'ailleurs de plusieurs
planètes c'est mon hypothèse parce que
n'oubliez pas que nous on a 300 bilans
d'existence sur le plan intellectuel
l'homo sapiens est descendu de sa
branche et à peu près 300000 ans mais
l'univers à 14 milliards d'années bien
sûr donc il peut y avoir des
civilisations qui ont des millions ou
des milliards d'années d'avance par
rapport à nous et on ne peut même pas
imaginer
ce que serait une civilisation qui
aurait ne serait-ce que 200 000 ans
d'avance et là on parle de milliards
d'années et juste Jean-Claude est-ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir extraterrestre ça
veut dire bien sûr ils sont pas sur la
table donc il y a plusieurs types de
d'extraterrestres c'est-à-dire qu'il y
en a qui viennent peut-être de d'autres
planètes de Saturne de mars de Vénus
plutôt c'est fini
d'autres galaxies ils peuvent venir
différences c'est à dire que même eux
ils se disent
sauf ce que j'ai raconté la dernière
fois et c'était pas un contact
je n'ai pas de quoi oui la pieuvre je
n'ai pas de contact évidemment avec une
civilisation extraterrestre je travaille
là-dessus depuis 50 ans bien sûr je
rencontre des gens beaucoup plus 50 ans
Jean-Claude franchement aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu es capable de nous dire
travailler en plus 50 ans à partir de
combien de temps tu t'es dit c'est sûr
qu'ils sont là
ah mais je suis absolument certain
qu'ils sont là et à partir de combien
d'années de travail je t'ai dit assez
rapide parce que j'étais persuadé comme
beaucoup sans doute ici que tout ça
c'était des bêtises ça me faisait bien
rigoler pas moi et quand j'ai vu les
dossiers de l'armée les dossiers de la
gendarmerie que j'ai rencontré des gens
des services secrets des scientifiques
de haut niveau qui n'osaient pas en
parler publiquement mais qui avait
travaillé déjà bien avant moi je me suis
dit mais c'est incroyable qu'on en parle
pas et heureusement que vous en avez
parlé on est justement Jean-Claude si ça
n'existait pas pourquoi il y a dans tous
les pays des cellules sur des cas
voilà des cas des cas voilà qui qui sont
pas résolus et qui ont dit des peu des
dossiers secrets dans tous les pays il y
a des cellules qui travaillent sur les
extraterrestres vrai ou pas et à mon
avis ils savent les gouvernements au
plus haut niveau savent j'ai donné la
dernière fois Emmanuel Macron il le sait
s'il y a des extraterrestres ou pas
pardon Emmanuel Macron il le sait ah je
ne sais pas il faudrait
Nicolas Sarkozy est-ce qu'il le sait il
faut lui poser la question vous savez il
y a des chefs d'État qui se préoccupent
de certains dossiers ou qui ont une
espèce de de d'intérêt pour en France
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr les services
secrets français comme les services
secrets des grands pays industrialisés
ont évidemment un dossier là-dessus et
ils le savent depuis longtemps moi j'ai
rencontré je l'ai dit la dernière fois
des gens des services secrets français
qui n'étaient pas du tout surpris parce
que j'avais vécu et qui me disait ça
c'est un coup des Soviétiques c'était
avant les 1989
on m'avait volé je l'ai raconté mais on
m'avait volé l'orange dans mon
appartement en plein jour sans fracturer
la porte une photo c'est un cambriolage
j'en ai pas une photo et cette photo
c'était pas n'importe quoi puisque
c'était la photo de la Réunion
confidentielle de tous les scientifiques
américains qui s'intéressaient aux ovnis
mais à titre privé donc ça avait un
intérêt mais c'était pas le document du
siècle et ben on est quand même venu me
laver chez moi ça c'est un coup de
service secret ça c'est ce que ça ça
prouve qu'il y a des extraterrestres
ça prouve que les gens des services
secrets s'intéressent au dossier des
extraterrestres et quand j'ai rencontré
le l'un des grands patrons des services
secrets français il y a 40 ans
je me souviens très bien de la
conversation il était avec deux colonel
et il m'a dit ça c'est un coup de
service secret soviétique ils veulent
savoir quels sont les Américains qui
travaillent sur le dossier des ovnis et
eux-mêmes n'étaient pas du tout surpris
par ce dossier juste Jean-Claude pour
noter les spectateurs aussi les
personnes que vous avez pu voir ils
travaillent sur ces dossiers les
personnes services secrets est-ce
qu'elles vous ont dit
sans aucune voilà il y avait aucune sans
aucun doute qu'il y avait des
extraterrestres en tout cas qui avait
une vie extraterrestre en dehors de la
terre est-ce que ils vous ont dit qu'ils
extraterrestres venaient parfois sur
terre ou pas bien sûr mais vous savez il
y a pas que les gens des services
secrets qu'ils disent il y a toutes les
religions monsieur
vraiment pour vous il y a aucun doute
pour moi il y a absolument aucun doute
c'est pourquoi on les voit pas alors
mais peut-être que vous les voyez sans
le savoir
mais non vous démontrez la présence des
extraterrestres comme la présence de
Dieu on peut c'est des convictions mais
on s'arrête là on peut aller dire de
plus de croire en Dieu ou pas mais c'est
très bien je suis ravi de vous être à
l'étude puis 50 ans mais pour l'instant
ce sont des convictions et quelqu'un qui
est venu chez vous tout ce que ça prouve
c'est quelqu'un vous a volé un truc
c'est pas c'est pas je veux dire c'est
malin vous êtes charmante c'est
tellement très brillant mais pour
l'instant non mais c'est pas dans il a
d'autres infos Jean-Claude Jean-Claude
quand on vous dit saxo vous l'aurez
répondez à tous les gens qui vous
prennent pour un fou moi ça ne me gêne
absolument pas je l'ai dit en long large
et en travers je mourrai tranquille
parce que j'ai une certitude qui est pas
basée sur du fanatisme si quelqu'un
venait me démontrer que les c'est des
millions de preuves qu'il y a mais il
faut avoir le temps d'aller les chercher
et nous les appréhender dans la totalité
ils nous ont donné deux trois comme ça
ce qu'il y en a des millions preuve la
première preuve que les extraterrestres
existent c'est que Cyril Hanouna existe
ah oui parce que pourquoi êtes-vous là
pourquoi sommes-nous là est-ce que vous
croyez un truc business
est-ce que vous croyez que la nature
comme on dit c'est à dire les atomes
issus du Big Bang
sur d'autres intelligences bien plus
avancées
non mais je me demandais justement pas
là
c'est le darwinisme mais après
que les extraterrestres sont beaucoup
plus intelligents que nous bah oui c'est
ça c'est sûr donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
viennent pas nous c'est sûr je ne peux
pas vous dire pourquoi ils viennent pas
nous voir apparemment
ils viennent nous voir vous savez hier
j'ai vu en avant-première un film qui se
rapprochait à Cannes sur
sur l'affaire de Monsieur Maurice mas en
1965 une histoire extraordinaire alors
Monsieur masse un agriculteur 6 heures
du matin il va dans son champ de lavande
c'est dans le sud de la France il pense
à tous aux fausses extraterrestres donc
il se fiche et évidemment éperdument et
puis vaut au milieu de son champ de
lavande ce qui prend pour une voiture en
disant il y a que des Parisiens qui
peuvent venir en plein milieu de mon
champ de lavande il s'avance il voit que
c'est pas une voiture que c'est un ovni
qui a deux petits extraterrestres qui
sont au pied de l'ovni et puis il
s'avance il s'avance c'est l'un des deux
extraterrestres prend à son côté un tube
creux le dirige sur monsieur masque est
instantanément paralysé les deux petits
bonhommes remontent dans l'ovni et il
la réaction est tout à fait
significative
la gendarmerie et sur place elle fait
des prélèvements elle fait des
interrogatoires les services secrets
aussi et c'est l'un des cas français
extrêmement bien enquêté pour lesquels
on a toujours aucune espèce
d'explication
ça a changé complètement sa vie il est
rentré chez lui dans un état second
quand on sait ce que c'est que les
paysans qui ont travaillé à 6h du matin
on se doute bien qu'il y a eu quelque
chose et aujourd'hui on a fait refait
refait l'enquête on ne sait toujours pas
ce qu'il a vu
ça c'est histoire voilà ça c'est une
preuve ça c'est une preuve en tout cas
ça j'encule merci Jean-Claude on casse
toujours extrêmement intéressant et je
vais te dire à Jean-Claude
moi je rigole tout ça mais je le sais
moi j'y crois à fond franchement et j'y
crois vraiment à 100% je te le dis je
suis comme toi
le général israélien qui a fait des
déclarations que je vous invite à
regarder et retrouver sur le web et lui
c'est pas un rigolo vous verrez c'est un
scientifique de haut niveau professeur
d'université il a dirigé les satellites
autour de la terre d'Israël etc c'est
pas il fait des créations beaucoup plus
musclé que celle que je viens de faire